cardi be kicked off the 2019 BT Awards
by giving a lap dance to her man offset
while performing their hit clouts
greatest performance great show setting
the tone for a night full of
entertainment excitement and emotion
it's gonna be a great show but we do
have some fun surprises Regina Hall
hosted the show starting the evening
with an epic opening number inspired by
Beyonce's homecoming even taraji P
Henson got in on the action
[Applause]
[Music]
then lizzo took the stage I've been
making music as a big black woman for
big black women and so now this just
shows that my music is finally reaching
the black community and I'm just so
excited to just share with my people
today she had the whole crowd height
especially Rihanna who has been Gerling
in her seat RiRi was at the show for a
very important reason to present the
Lifetime Achievement Award to mary j
blige happy Mary's bad mary mad mary no
more drama mary and on behalf of all the
women and came after you like myself
thank you for being you so we could feel
comfortable being ourselves and it means
so much to me i mean to be alive to you
know to live through so much my fans
have been there the whole time so you
know i'm here to celebrate all of us
well nas acts and Billy Ray Cyrus
brought their country Flair riding in on
horses before singing their hip old town
road
[Music]
there were also poignant moments
throughout the night like Tyler Perry's
moving speech after he was presented
with the ultimate icon award when I
built my studio I built it in a
neighborhood that is one of the poorest
black neighborhoods in Atlanta so the
young black kids could see that a black
man did that and they can do it too it's
pretty awesome really really excited
about this and they didn't have to do
this so I'm really really excited there
was also a touching tribute to late
rapper Nipsey Hussle who was honored
with the Humanitarian Award his daughter
Imani wiped away tears in the audience
before joining his family and girlfriend
Lauren London onstage to express their
thanks I just want to thank you guys for
all the loving support and the marathon
continues again
[Applause]
[Music]